what's going on guys today is a big day
in the geek culture studios we have been
waiting months for this months
you know since the socatano the
mandalorian helmet
it's finally arrived
this is a global first unboxing of
hasbro's force fx elite of the dark
saber
this is it
whoa i cannot wait
zach are you ready are you excited
zackie yeah of course you don't sound
excited be excited jackie yeah yeah
yeah
[Music]
this video is brought to you by secret
lab now here at geek culture we really
like our secret lab chairs as a matter
of fact we use them primarily for all
the work we do and they come in a
variety of different sizes omega titan
titan xl and talk about fabrics and
materials you got pu 2.0 leather you got
genuine leather and also soft weave and
in terms of collaboration we got world
of warcraft dota lol dc characters
harley quinn joker batman even game of
thrones there is a secret lab chair for
you for more information click on the
link in the description below
okay i do want to say this we did not
steal this from the hasbro factory
because we get these questions from our
transformer reviews that did not happen
thank you hasbro singapore for sending
this over to us uh we are really honored
to be able to unbox this with you guys
here i have not seen this the tape is on
it
i am experiencing this the same way you
guys are in this video
man i can't wait oh man i mean i've seen
you know variations of the dark saber
through you know independent saber uh
companies out there especially sabre
mock in singapore they had a prototype
that we saw which we couldn't obviously
photograph or film
so i'm i'm excited to see what haswell
has done with this is this a must buy is
this a pass
let's find out okay now we're going to
bring out the official geek culture
unboxing knife
it's pink in color because
why is it pink zucchini
because it's fun bobby but we need blue
or green geek culture
colors go fixing impulse fantastic okay
hold up hold that up first okay and then
three two one and there we go okay yeah
see the power
tv wow
it's even better built
you're really good first before we get
to the unboxing let's talk about the
outside of the box as we need to do here
in the studios as you can see we have
them off gideon here we have mandalorian
this is coming right from the tv show
all the way force effects elite right
here this is a heavy box guys i mean
from the ahsoka tano uh
saber to this this is feels more robust
so
i'm guessing
this has got to be all metal man this
has got to be
this is gonna be amazing okay now we're
gonna move to the back of it real quick
here
and
we have the entire dark saber with these
arrows here i hope it doesn't have
arrows in it please don't have arrows in
it because i don't want to be directing
traffic it shouldn't have arrows so on
this we've got the standard stand that's
on the same as all the other lightsabers
so republic empire i hear the comments
in the section below obviously we have
this for the blade effect pointed
they'll sing in very different languages
which i can't speak so yes international
box international languages we'll find
out when we unbox it right now okay
first always save the box for
collectibles because you never know
it could be worth a lot of money one day
because as far as i know this is the
first dark saver hasbro's ever made
this is a very difficult thing to unbox
actually when you look at it because
it's like if you untap it here it's yeah
it's just
okay
unboxing could be improved number one we
get here to the center to the area here
says star wars force effects elite
the black series
you've got your instruction manual here
everything is wrapped up we're removing
the cardboard i'm so excited for the
zacky you have no idea i am super
excited for this all right so now we're
going to uh
take out the instruction manual here
with all our documentation safety
documents because hasbro want us to be
safe at all times
we've got
the star wars the black series
mandalorian dark saber force effects
elite structure manual then also we have
mandalorian
moth getting on the back of it
this explains how to put the batteries
in
everything else because
it batteries we know it's sound battery
wait a second
what
no
it's a battery pack so you can charge us
by usb yep oh sweet
finally
finally we don't need like double a or
aaa batteries for these things and here
is the usb cable
okay it's micro usb
yeah yeah you gotta go usbc in 2021
hasbro you drop the ball on that one but
at least you got usb charging small
thing small at least you can charge it
by a usb here is the stand as we've seen
on the ahsoka tano uh lightsaber as well
some people say empire motif in republic
honestly
looks like the empire motif to me but
anyway it's the standard stand that is
holds the lightsaber vertically without
the blade of course so that is going
over here
now we've got
this piece of plastic which i don't know
what it looks like yet or what it's used
for yet we will find out in the
instruction manual first we're going to
take out the hilt
oh this is heavy
oh
wow
are we serious with this yo this is full
metal excellent this is a weapon
wow hold on a second let's take a look
at this for a sec
okay
this has got to be like
three two three kilos
this is heavy
or in america that's about maybe a
couple of few pounds but this is really
this is no joke
you are not doing any sort of uh combat
saber savoring with this thing at all
what you wouldn't want to do it anyway
but even cosplayers out there
be warned
this
is
hefty
how okay i could
curl
yeah
get out of here did the choppa i got the
dark saber now
you don't have it anymore mandalorian
arnold makes his appearance in season
three or the mandalorian
let's move on to the blade
ah so this is one of the most important
things of this because it's the first
time we're seeing a lightsaber with this
flat designed blade to it
now
first impressions of this we don't know
how it lights up yet but you know in the
dark saber that we saw in the
mandalorian series there was these sort
of like these cracklings of white light
that would go through it
a little bit not too much
and also in some of the independent dark
sabers i've seen on the market they had
a little bit of that as well on this one
it looks like it's a matte black all the
way through now it's not painted on
there as you can see here we can go
closer to it it's sort of a plastic
piece on each side that is uh
attached to it so it's sort of
it's not it's not i would say
inexpensively made it looks wealthy it
looks like it's good quality we get to
the the area here where you slot it in
and obviously this is a very interesting
contraption the way that it's designed
so we'll see how that works in just a
minute
but um
it's not really sharp at the end of it
so that's fine you're not going to poke
anyone to hurt anybody and it has some
not that heavy so i would say the
standard probably the standard
lightsaber blade would be a little bit
heftier than this but of course it is
flat so it would help reduction away but
gonna see how lights up we gotta see how
this lights up because that is where
this is gonna be
a must buy
or maybe a pass
so we have removed the box we've got the
essentials on the table
we have read the instructions a little
bit and so we'll walk you through what
each of the parts are now this one part
here that zacky was saying was the hill
is actually for the stand so you can
actually put it in vertically
so
how it works is this
you can actually put this in like that
all right and it stays
however if you want to light it up you
have the lights that come on the side of
the hilt and you can leave that
on your display as well
look how cool this is now i want to put
a disclaimer on this because of the
weight of this
if you have a glass cabinet like we have
here okay
um
please be careful
because if this drops because of the
weight
it will crack that glass
it will it is
that heavy guys uh so i would definitely
err on the side of caution
when displaying this making sure that
it's on a very stable shelf or table
because you don't want to break glass or
anything like that okay this is not a
kid's product it says 14 and above but
based on this alone
this is a weapon if someone breaks into
your house you can use the hilt to
attack them
and you'll probably win okay
so just keep that in mind
let's turn that off so i can just hold
this down to turn it off
already right away i can say that the
switch for to turn it on the button to
turn it on and the blaster effects
button here
feels a lot better than the ahsoka
tano's saber so
hats off to hasbro for that um just to
kind of go talk about the hilt a little
bit more before we get into all this
though
i love the grooves here the paintwork is
well done you got this kind of like a
graphite gray to black
in there it has a really nice design
you've got this gloss black paint on the
top here
and it looks a little bit different than
of course the handle
but it works and especially when it's
lit up it adds a nice effect to it so
um and there's a lot of detail and
design here throughout the hilt area
where the blade goes into
you can see there's been a lot of
attention to detail on this so you got
to give to hasbro for this i mean
obviously they're having access to the
actual one they're using in the
mandalorian series so this will probably
be most
screen accurate out of all of them i
mean
size-wise i mean again
i haven't seen the actual dark saber or
in display any sort of like museum or
any sort of uh exhibition thus far from
the series but i'm guessing this has got
to be pretty screen accurate um we are
seeing some allen keys here uh case in
point there is an allen key uh
section right here and there is a full
one right here so you got to keep that
in mind because you're going to have to
use the allen key to
put in the battery
pack as well as to put in the blade okay
and you got to make sure that you use
the correct allen key because one is
full one is real so just be on the
lookout for that probably don't do it
you know under the influence of alcohol
right zacky
hey can i promise you anything bro
okay fair enough what's cool here on
this is actually there are a couple
parts i've just turned it on to light
this up does it be all the way out
jackie yeah
it doesn't come with an extra screw so
uh i would definitely say this something
you probably could find in a hardware
store so just uh you know maybe you want
to pick up an extra one just to be safe
that would always be good because in
case you do you lose it
then you won't be able to
do these things now we take off this
piece of metal
part of the hilt first right as you can
see here
we've got the light uh window here where
the leds showing okay and then you can
pull this piece out now this is sort of
to protect what's inside and also kind
of give you that um full look without
the blade in there so that is also metal
everything on this thing is metal right
now guys this is a really robust hilt
um i can't
emphasize enough how heavy this thing is
but it's really heavy and when you look
inside it's not a neopixel blade guys
this is just an led blade as you can see
right here zac you see if we can zoom in
on that real quick
yep
so you can see the connections right
there and the lights protruding and as
we pull the battery out
oh look at the design on this
this is quite nice
there's a lot of design motif on this
battery case in point see all the lines
there looks like circuitry whatever the
case may be and it goes all the way
around the battery of course there's
safety information etc etc but
this looks like it's removable so we
have a screwdriver here
and we're going to actually
unscrew this to see what kind of battery
it is
because over time you probably have to
replace this
and if you do
what battery do you replace it with
ah
this is your battery right here it looks
like a rechargeable lithium-ion battery
so you can find your batteries out so
this is not a standard battery per se
maybe you have to contact hasbro or
whatever the case may be i'm not a
battery expert
but this is what's powering this entire
saber is here
um so keep that in mind
so but yeah this is a little bit of a
process to truly
charge this thing because now you can
only charge it
outside of the
the hilt there's the usb port right here
so this is the micro usb port here
on this side
and we've got it plugged in do you ever
wonder what this hole is on our desk
here we have usb ports
we charge that in plug that in
and
it's red
so i guess when it's green is charged
i mean we don't know we
you know is our first unboxing of this
but
there you go this is how you charge the
battery
to the dark saber
very cool do wish it was usbc you know
it's 2021
micro usb
but
it is what it is
so to put the blade in first you're
going to actually put this metal sheath
over the blade
and
bring it all the way to the end
okay
now
you're gonna slide this in
ever so like this
all right
see that
lock sure make sure it's there it's
locked in it's good then you got to
tighten this thing up with
the allen key and the screw once again
first off this is a long hilt as you can
see and i've got pretty large hands so i
can grab this with both hands here now
this part of my hand is really getting
to the button area here i don't want to
turn this on yet we've got to wait for
the unveiling but just to let you know
in terms of how it feels it is solid
there is no movement with this blade
inside of the hilt it's locked in there
of course we've got this screwed in so
it's pretty tight
this is not a combat saver guys i
wouldn't try it
this is for display for cosplay purposes
only
but you know
length is good
i love the whole black effect dark
effect on it
and
yeah this feels really nice
i would venture to say already right now
this feels better than ahsoka tano's
blade
in terms of the whole construction and
everything else
and i think uh you guys out there if you
were like you know i don't want
something that feels inexpensive you're
not going to get it with this
but now
the moment of truth to turn on the dark
saber
for the first time
zach you ready
here we
three
go
[Music]
huh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
does it get any louder
yeah first impressions
audio is a little low
i was expecting this to be louder and uh
i mean i don't know if this is due to
charging or what or because it's a metal
hilt that the speakers aren't
i mean it sounds loud when you kind of
move it to the side it's a bit of a
delay
ah
okay guys
here it is
here are the speakers right here okay if
you hold it like a normal lightsaber
nothing
you can actually accidentally turn it
off too so
you're going to want to hold it down
here to get maximum sound which is a
little bit odd honestly i think that
down here would have been better right
yeah because you hold it here
you
you cover
so now we're gonna do a sound comparison
between the dark saber and ahsoka tano
saber here
because
yeah this is quite low so okay let me
move my hand away we're gonna turn this
on
no like
like there's no sound like that with
this it's just
yeah there's nothing like wow
oh my god
you know like that first time you turn
on a saber it's like okay
as opposed
now of course there's delayed reaction
on this as well like the dark saber
but the sound is coming from here
so no matter where you hold it on the
hill you're always going to get that
sound
versus
this one
it's right here so if i hold it normally
i'm covering the speakers
so here's to my mic so you guys can hear
what i'm talking about
even the turning on
see how loud that is
right
and
here's the dark saber
really
anticlimactic is the word this is very
anticlimactic come on this is
let's not talk about sound for a moment
let's go to the blade okay because this
is obviously one of the more important
parts of this sabre because this is very
unique um we've never seen an official
saber from hasbro or from disney or from
star wars or lucasfilm for that matter
that
has this design but let's look at this
for a second so in the middle there you
have this black plastic area as i
mentioned earlier in this review it's
not painted on there it's like another
piece that is
glued on or it's adhesive to it where
it's stuck onto the light portion of it
you can see those individual led lights
all the way through this to the very top
and around
however though we want to be screen
accurate for a moment when you look at
the dark saber let's say in the
mandalorian or even in the animated
series you are going to see some little
bit of light like uh crackling coming
through to the black area just ever so
slight and you don't have that here so
it's just a very definitive black line
to the white lights here now you get a
little bit of that unevenness with the
led lights here somewhere a little bit
brighter than the other so i think
that's what hasbro was trying to do
replicate that unevenness with the dark
saber with these leds
but i wish it was a little bit brighter
as a matter of fact zach can we turn off
the lights here for a second let's see
how it looks in the dark
i mean this is pretty wicked i mean just
looking at it right now personally
this looks cool
i do wish it was a bit brighter though
because i think a bit brighter would
even make that
light border around the dark saber even
more pronounced
but again on screen or on camera that
you're seeing right now it might look a
little bit brighter than i see it in
person now in terms of the blaster
effect button here when you press it
you're going to see
there's individual leds that light up
red right
which is kind of cool gives a little bit
more uh something unique that stands out
but if you hold it down
you're gonna get this effect here
so it's like if you're impaling a wall
or if you're impaling somebody you know
what i mean or if you're clashing a
saber with somebody else you're gonna
get this burn effect so you've got red
orange yellow i don't know if you guys
see it exactly on screen it's ever so
slight but it is quite cool and of
course you get the sound effects with it
[Music]
i mean i have to say the sound profiles
are really good on it it's just
unfortunately the volume is when you
have your hand there it's not so good
and as you saw right there this button
right here to turn on the saber is very
easy to press now in ahsoka tanos it was
more difficult because you had to really
use your fingernail or dig your finger
in there to press you know the button to
turn it on but here if i'm holding
holding the saber moving it around
i can automatically turn it off like
that
and then if i just turn it on like that
as well so if you want that flick of the
wrist action you can do that but
it would have been nice if there was a
little bit of a
i would say more tension on the button
so you don't accidentally press it just
by swinging it around
yeah it's lackluster and it shouldn't be
because
with the dark saber and it's got i mean
the sound profiles are accurate you know
based on our research obviously there's
various different sound profiles
depending on how you use the saber but
for when it's you know the turned on and
that pulsating sound of what it has it's
accurate
but it's really low
so
i mean i don't know hasbro if you're
watching this maybe you guys can
increase the volume internally on this
before you send it out to other people i
mean they say this is a production set i
don't know we're the first to have it
um but i would definitely like boost
this up
like five or ten decibels you know what
i mean like make it loud because with
the speakers here on the hilt right here
you're going to cover it with your hand
you know so you lose all that sound like
you hear like you can barely hear
anything
now you hear or even put a sound profile
there something because
here is just really
not a good place to have it yes bro you
can be better than this for those of you
who've gone to galaxy's edge and you
picked up a lightsaber there it's that
same kind of build quality so i applaud
hasbro for
uh bringing that into the forcefx elite
series with that because that's what it
feels like metal robust all the way
through
but the speakers on it are just
lackluster
it is what it is you're right zacky it
is what it is but i
you know what
maybe
maybe it'll sound better with the
mandalorian helmet on hold on seriously
how many baby odas do you guys have here
like
are you guys obsessed baby here here
here here here here here voila
[Applause]
wow
now i rule mandalore
this is cool
okay
sounds about the same but i look cooler
holding the saber now right zacky yeah
you do man now now i now i look the part
just need one more thing
get over here little guy
all right baby grogu we're gonna need
your opinion on this okay
thank you
is the darksaber
a must-buy
i know it doesn't sound that good
right
build quality is fantastic
um
i like the construction
feels great
but what do you think of the sound
same thing
it is what it is
conclusions
great build quality
i
actually like the blade overall i mean i
wish it was a little bit brighter i wish
there was a little bit more effects you
can do with it
but okay for the first of its kind it's
legit if you're a cosplay player that's
going to be using this for your outfit
you're going to notice that the sound
you're not going to hear much if you're
actually grabbing onto the saber if
you're just more for
showing in your case you want to pull it
out once in a while okay great
but uh hopefully uh hasbro can before
they release this to the general public
increase the volume of the speaker by
like five or ten decibels because it
definitely needs it and with a much more
impactful turning on and turning off
sound that i think would that would
really make this dark saber a must
must-have i mean collectors are going to
buy this anyway
but for
you know if you're on the fence
and you're not you know married to
having a
uh
fully licensed saber
you might look elsewhere if you want
that sound and that more interesting in
terms of lighting
but uh
i mean i i like i do like this overall
it's just
i was hoping for a little bit louder but
anyway let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below is this something
that you're going to pick up no matter
what are you on the fence of the dark
saber does the volume
of this
make you want to cancel your order i'd
love to hear from you guys anyway with
that guys follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube like this
video it helps us out a lot stay safe
out there and we'll chat to you soon
take care
bobby you know what time it is
yeah it's time to release
the kraken i wanted to say the mendo cut
but okay
okay you know what i do yeah okay mando
cut here we go
mando cut time oh cut three two one go
running out of breath
likes it
yes he does